[Music]
400 million years ago giant mushrooms
the size of houses dominated the land
yet over time they disappeared and
evolved into the smaller versions we
know and love today but what if we found
a way to bring them back
why did joint mushrooms go extinct what
would happen if they survived and grew
on our planet and would they be
beneficial or harmful this is what if
and here's what would happen if giant
mushrooms grew on earth during the
Devonian period about 420 to 350 million
years ago plants had not yet fully
flourished and were merely a few feet
tall still massive mushrooms or
prototype cities were plentiful due to
the rich supply of bacteria found in the
soil this special soil known as crypto
biotic soil harbored a crust of living
organisms made up of fungi mosses green
algae bacteria and lichens at this point
in time much of Earth's land was covered
in this soil which made it the perfect
breeding ground for fungi believe it or
not
ancient mushrooms didn't have caps which
thankfully allowed generous sunlight for
vascular plants to evolve prototype
cities were pivotal in their progress as
they acted as symbiotic routes for
plants the mushrooms feeding tubes known
as hyphy secreted organic acids to
dissolve rocks and extract nutrients in
a process known as biological weathering
plants in turn would absorb the sunlight
through photosynthesis and transfer
energy to the mushrooms
they were essentially besties for life
if it weren't for gigantic fungi we may
not have forests or oxygen-rich
environments to harbor complex life
forms such as ourselves today vast
networks of mycelium allow trees to
transfer essential nutrients to one
another it's like a fully organic form
of the Internet - all the spam and memes
in the mushroom Network things go viral
in a totally different way fungi has
been used to cure deadly viruses and
comprises the basis of life-saving
antibiotics such as penicillin they've
also been found to digest hydrocarbons
in petroleum and polyurethane plastics
and absorb heavy metals like mercury
scientists have even discovered a
species of fungi in Chernobyl that feeds
on radiation which converts it into
chemical energy in a process called
Radio synthesis in a way having mega
mushrooms all over the planet could
solve a lot of problems like pollution
or cleaning up oil spills and
radioactive areas but what are the risks
could giant mushrooms hurt our planet
although many forms of fungi are
beneficial out of 1.5 million species on
earth at least 300 of them are poisonous
to us if we try to introduce them back
into our ecosystem we would need to be
very careful about their toxicity as the
most widely distributed organisms on
earth many of them remain a mystery to
us
we would need a team of experts to
manage their harvest around the world
just as forest managers regulate our
tree harvesting without proper care
these mighty mushrooms could gobble up
all the vital nutrients for plant life
to grow and become an invasive species
and since fungi also inhale oxygen and
exhale carbon dioxide humans would have
a rapid rival for the air we breathe
giant mushrooms likely couldn't survive
in today's world unless they were
carefully contained as there is already
too much competition from plants
scientists are still debating why
prototypes ''tis went extinct but there
are a couple of theories either they
didn't grow fast enough to recover from
animals eating them or the abundance of
vascular plants out competed them for
nutrients so maybe they are hearty size
actually proved their downfall
nevertheless if we found a way to grow
these giants again we could use
mushrooms in many interesting ways
how about Sun reflectors sources of
shade culinary delicacies medicine
garbage absorbers transcendental healing
or at the very least trampolines to
bounce around on okay that's maybe not
the safest idea but it would really put
the fun in fungi in all honesty we have
a lot to thank our ginormous fungi
friends for they fostered the forest
which gave us oxygen rich environments
allowing complex animals like humans to
evolve though presumably we won't have
giant mushrooms similar to the Devonian
period anytime soon it's interesting to
wonder if humans could have survived
back then
that's a story for another what if
[Music]